last move played was Pawn to E5 striking
in the center
it's a kid people who are not familiar
with the kid you think oh wait I have
two attackers here let me go win the
pawn Irene is like no none of that
because had she decided to take twice
this bishop stares at this Knight
there's often ways to play moves like
Knight takes E4 and get this Knight on
E5 but James I feel like if I were on
the
um the team right if I were a Charlotte
Cobra team member I'd be saying to Arena
if you can play a forced draw get to an
end game you go for that we need that
half Point against Magnus Carlson
collaboration
hey Magnus put this on bro put this
put this on yeah I think it could look
good on him and look at Irina by the way
he spent a bunch of time she was King to
H1 there's still this pinned down the E
file and magnets can go upon grabbing
but there's often this like Knight B5
move in many positions that you go after
these vulnerable dark squares and you
can of course just take back on e4 The
Rook will get an open file if you have
pawns out the way the queen goes to B3
at the right moment and F7 is very
tender so look at white being ahead in
terms of development you have three
minor pieces developed black only is one
and so if you just go Pawn grabbing you
may pay the price but Magnus he's
finally thinking that's Checkmate in one
if she doesn't see it oh yeah we
actually knew this was coming because of
the time issue that she had early on in
the game we knew this was coming here
and Magnus used his time to get an
advantage oh yikes made on the back rank
quick smile and happens the game's over
there made on the back right Carlson and
I read a crush is so strong she's a
grand master I mean she's
um won some major events and here Magnus
made it look easy just to show you
quickly that the pieces came off and in
this end game it says slightly better
for black and he made her pay because
Black's uh Pawn structure is a bit
better The Rook is active some isolated
Pawn on T4 Target on A2 and Magnus
brought his rook in and then never let
her back in the game but pushing his
pawns and then finally trading off his
weakness look at this James C takes B3
please take my Rook back here
unfortunately for you you know I can
just take back and you can't take the
bishop for example uh so you can also
play B2 and after a rook B1 over here
you're going to give up this rook and
then the ensuing position is just bad
across the board so nice win there for
Magnus going after all these weaknesses